now it's time for you to go create a
folder structure for your project inside
you're going to need a CSS file for your
framework and you'll also need a test
HTML file the structure you create for
your portfolio folder should look
something like this and you can use the
structure you created in the last lesson
make sure that you have a folder for
your CSS files because we might need
more than one and large projects that's
pretty common so it's a good idea to
have this organization from the very
beginning I'm going to do two things to
make sure that this is correct first off
I'm going to create a style in main CSS
which is going to be linked in test HTML
then I'll open up test HTML with some
code in it just to test and we'll make
sure that those CSS Styles in main dot
CSS are applying to test HTML within
test HTML I created a link to main CSS
which is of course within the CSS
directory inside the body I added
framework test page and I included it
within an h1 tag in main dot CSS to make
sure it's working I change the color of
the h1 tag to green so we should see the
text framework test page show up in the
page in green let's take a look so I'm
over in the browser I'll go to file open
which lets me open this test HTML file
I'll click open and here we see
framework test page show up in green
let's just triple check to make sure
this is right let's change the color to
blue and see if it works
save come back over I will hit refresh
and now framework test pages in blue so
we know we've got our HTML and CSS files
in the right place
now I want you to set up your folder
structure and files when you're done it
should look like what you see here check
this box when you're ready to move on